during the the 70s and the 80s the old
East Germany basically we're putting an
awful lot of nasty steroids testosterone
into the young girls as a program really
to you know to win in sport uh they
totally dominated in the women's events
obviously because what they could do was
they could create a sort of a male
puberty by giving these young girls
these terrible drugs from about 11 and
with massive side effects many of them
have been really poorly some have even
died this was allowed to go on for a
very long time
um the girl that beat me was was from
East Germany I've met her since and
she's got liver problems and kidney
problems and fertility problems and all
sorts of things they had big court cases
when the war came down in 89. we were
all very aware of it at the time you
knew it was happening oh yes I mean
because they would turn up you know at a
major competition we'd never seen them
before
they would look and sound like men they
had deep voices and you know Shadows on
their chins bless them and bad skin and
and and and male physique and they swam
like males you know they would do male
equivalent times
um
then they disappear again and we see
another one and the next major
competition you know and they would have
no hardly any success in the men's races
and this massive success in the women's
races so at European level they won 92
percent of the women's medals throughout
that whole period of time and
practically none in the men's and the
ioc went well they're not doing anything
and it was really really frustrating I
mean really frustrating and I suppose
that's why I speak out now it's the
biggest reason I speak out now because I
had friends that came forth behind three
Germans and their whole lives would have
been different have they been Olympic
champions and you use that term really
frustrating but
that isn't Sharon surely you know you've
dedicated your life to this your
childhood you every day eight hours a
day and all of a sudden somebody cheats
yeah it's more than frustrating isn't it
it's the Injustice of it I suppose it
was the Injustice of it for all of us
because even at the time we knew that
they weren't doing it kind of I I I'm
reluctant to say not knowing because I
think they must have known something was
going on no their bodies were changes
their voices were changing you know you
they're going to ask questions they're
not stupid however there was very little
they could do about it so they weren't
in a position where they could control
it because what we showed I did a
documentary
um a few years ago and we went to the
Stasi files and and we could see that
they were making about a nine percent
Improvement so you could take a very
average swimmer a female swimmer if you
make you know nine percent Improvement
you make them world record holders so
they had this total you know they had an
infinite number of young girls they
could just move into the system fill
them from these terrible drugs and have
them as world champion so they didn't
need to look after their best swimmers
because they had a train of just young
girls you know that they were removing
from their families and putting them
into training programs so it was
horrendous what was done and you know
there's there was always two victims
there was a victims that were cheated
like myself and my friends
um and there were these young girls that
were incredibly badly let down you know
by the ioc and why didn't the ioc get
involved in why did they not because if
it was as clear as day and it was really
does sound like it why did they not do
something and they still do nothing now
wow so we've had all the evidence we've
got all the paperwork we had Germans
they had court cases where I think 25
million euros were given out in
compensation we've had um you know
admissions of guilt I've got admissions
of guilt from the the young woman that
beat me on tape the ioc was still doing
nothing
and you just kind of you just I I find
it Beggars belief when they're supposed
to be promoting Fair sport you know
Sharon talk to us about your friends and
obviously you don't have to go into you
know personal details if you don't want
to but I think one of the things that
often gets missed in this whole
conversation is what sort of impact in
the competitive environment where it's
not a percentage thing it's not like
well you know this person got promoted
unfairly and they get three percent more
money and you don't it's like you either
won or you didn't yeah and the gap
between those two is is as you say
life-changing yeah it's absolutely the
commercial gap between being an Olympic
champion and being forced and no one
ever remembering who you were is huge
you know it's absolutely huge it's
totally life-changing and so it's that
ability to have that opportunity which I
was not prepared to let happen all over
again the same end result in the fact
that male puberty is enabling someone to
have an advantage you know one was
artificial
with these German system one is a
natural process now and I just thought I
can't let this happen again I can't sit
by and watch a whole another generation
of young girls miss out and it's worse
really because in lots of ways with the
transgender argument is
um you've got all of the pathways you've
got all of the Masters events you've got
it across every sport across every
country whereas in my day it was just
the elite level and it was just
predominantly in say swimming rowing and
track and field you know it wasn't going
to affect the British national
championships or the American European
you know college trials or any of those
things whereas now it's affecting all
young women across the whole world
they're not getting their opportunities
to their success and it might be an
Olympic medal which is huge or it might
just be the fact that you make it to the
National the nc2as and you get to put
this on your you know on your CV for the
rest of your life which opens the door
for you when you're going for a job
application they're losing those
opportunities and that's not fair and of
course in America just to flesh that
point out a little bit because of the
way the whole sporting and college
system linked you could you could get to
college that you might not be able to
afford
and get a really good education based on
your athletic performance and yet here
you are
competing with people who are male
bodied to put a very which is the truth
the truth is that they are male bodied
and that will never change their
biological sex will always be male no
matter how much testosterone they reduce
no matter how much plastic surgery they
might choose to have and again that
doesn't happen in sport they don't have
plastic surgery they don't have genitals
removed you know and in a lot of cases
they try to reduce testosterone for
incredibly short periods of time uh like
Leah Thomas you know with the nc2as Leah
was asked to reduce her testosterone
levels to 10 animals of testosterone per
Lisa well that's 10 times what I have
and that was only for one year
I mean so the the difference is just
ridiculous that person goes from being
460th in America not in the world in the
world they would be not in the top 2000
in America 200 to being number one and
beating three American silver medalists
in the space of a year
so I mean a very mediocre male athlete
becomes a very elite female athlete and
all those Elite female athletes have
spent 10 years of their life making huge
sacrifices I just expected to step aside
and Sharon when was the first moment you
thought we've got a problem here
um it's been in the background for a
while
um up until 2015 the ISE allowed males
to identify females if they had got a
certificate and had had genital surgery
um in 2015 it changed and it's got
progressively worse I mean and to the
point now where the ioc don't even
suggest that anyone reduces testosterone
they just say you're not supposed to
suggest that anyone that's biologically
male has an advantage or that is the
most ludicrous thing to say because we
have men and women's races so if there's
no Advantage why are we having men and
women's races why don't we just have 100
meters on the track you know we know why
because we have two Sexes and so
therefore to offer opportunity across
Society we have all these different
types of categories and that's not just
male female that's age categories that's
para classifications that's weight
categories in boxing it's all sorts of
different categories to offer
Fair opportunity across Society
foreign